[Music]
Marvel wants to cast Pedro Pascal as the
lead in Fantastic 4 in fact the MCU is
currently undergoing quite a shakeup
generally there's a lot going on in
Hollywood not to mention the planned
John Wick anime curious well this and
much more awaits you in the Koch
news after Napoleon comes Hannibal the
next great General in world history will
receive a cinematic Masterpiece in 2024
for which director Antoine fuka will be
responsible in the leading role is
Denzel Washington according to deadline
streaming giant Netflix is planning a
Monumental historical epic about the
legendary General the man who crossed
the Alps on elephants and almost brought
down Rome The Equalizer director Antoine
fuka will direct the project while
Denzel Washington will be taking on the
starring role this will be the sixth
collaboration between the two in
addition to the three equalizer films
they also brought the Magnificent 7 and
Training Day to the big screen for the
latter Washington was awarded the
Academy Award for best actor in a
leading role the actor wanted to take on
the role of Hannibal 20 years ago
however family circumstances prevented
this and so the project was put on ice
for a long time now though the biopic
which is to be written by screenwriter
John Logan is finally getting back on
track Logan has already impressed with
the scripts for Martin scores The
Aviator and Ridley Scott's Gladiator
making him a connoisseur of historical
material it remains unclear when
Hannibal will be released on Netflix but
we'll keep you up to date as
always new release dates for Captain
America and the like after the end of
the actor strike Disney made some
adjustments and has now announced the
new release dates for the upcoming MCU
films the major delays concern Deadpool
3 Captain America 4 Brave New World
blade and Marvel's own version of The
Suicide Squad the Thunderbolts while
Deadpool 3 can't complete its production
in the next few months and will now open
on July 26th 2024 we will have to wait a
while longer for Captain America 4 Brave
New World the movie has been pushed back
by 9 months to February 14th 2025 the
Thunderbolts movie with Florence Pew and
Sebastian Stan will also not take on
their new Mission before 2025 more
precisely on July 25th 2025 the new
blade film with actor Mahala Ali is
expected to be released on November 7th
2025 however the reboot of Fantastic 4
is still scheduled for May 2nd 2025
something has also changed regarding the
big Avengers mov
while it is still uncertain whether
Marvel will really continue with Kang as
the villain director Dustin Daniel keton
has now resigned from Avengers the Kang
Dynasty he is currently resuming work on
the Disney plus series Wonderman and
then wants to focus primarily on Shang
Chi 2 the sequel to his first MCU film
meanwhile Insider Jeff Snyder reports
that Javier bardam is currently in talks
for the role of the villain Galactus the
character has long been requested by
Marvel fans for the MCU so these hopes
could soon become reality whatever
happens with the Avengers films good
news for John Wick fans the universe
surrounding the popular Hitman is to be
expanded with two new series with the
Amazon series the Continental we have
already been treated to the first
prequel of the world of John Wick this
year which dealt with Winston's rise to
become the manager of the Continental
hotel now two more series are to be
produced in which film director Chad
staheli will be involved stahelski
revealed in the playlist the discourse
podcast that he is working on two
promising new series The First One is
another spin-off series focusing on the
structures and scheming of the high
table the second one is an anime project
although no further information is
currently available the director also
explained that he could imagine one or
two of the characters from the previous
films appearing in the series he said he
loved Donnie Yen he loved Reena saama
and he loved the tracker the TV show
would be a good opportunity to explore
and expand the world of John Wick aside
from these new series fans are currently
waiting for the first spin-off film
ballerina starring Anna diis and Kiana
Reeves it is scheduled to hit theaters
on June 7th
2024 fan favorite Pedra Pascal could
play one of the leading roles in
Fantastic 4 according to various sources
Marvel is Keen on casting the star but
he actually has plenty to do with other
projects already according to both
Hollywood Insider Jeff Snyder and Daniel
Rickman Pedro Pascal is set to take on
the role of Reed Richards aka Mr
Fantastic the actor will be appearing in
the second season of The Last of Us in
2024 as well as in Ridley Scott's
Gladiator 2 and the Thriller weapons
according to Snider now that the strikes
are over they're busy checking schedules
to find a gap somewhere for the new MCU
Movie Marvel already had other actors in
mind for the role of Mr Fantastic prior
to the strike there were screen tests
with Christopher Abbott and Jamie Dornan
which didn't go so well however Adam
Driver and Jake Gyllenhaal were also in
talks but allegedly asked for too much
money MCU boss Kevin feige is becoming
more and more careful not to let the
budgets for the new films get out of
hand which is why according to The
Insider Emma Stone was also ultimately
not given the role of Sue storm in fact
this character is set to be the focus of
the next Fantastic 4 movie and is now
rumored to be played by Vanessa Kirby
meanwhile Joseph Quinn is the hottest
candidate for Johnny Storm while eban
Moss backrack is being considered for
the role of Ben GM W division director
Matt shackman is to take over as
director while the final screenplay will
be written by Avatar 2 author Josh
Friedman the theatric release for the
new Fantastic 4 movie is slated for May
2nd
2024 by the power of gry skull this
iconic Shout uttered by Prince Adam
Alias He-Man could soon be heard on the
big screen again as Amazon is rumored to
be working on a movie of the popular
fantasy franchise a new film adaptation
of the popular Masters of the Universe
toy franchise has been on Hollywood's
to-do list for years the streaming
service Netflix was the last to plan a
movie and had already secured a cast
member for He-Man in the in the form of
the map of tiny perfect things actor
Kyle Allen however after it became
impossible to finance the final budget
of over $200 million for the project
Netflix scrapped it according to variety
however there are now increasing rumors
that the Masters of the Universe film
might be back on track according to
initial Insider reports Amazon MGM
studio is currently in intensive talks
to realize the live-action film
adaptation Amazon apparently wants to
stick with the project and lead actor
Kyle Allen to bring the fantasy
Adventure to the big screen whether the
He-Man movie will actually end up on
Amazon remains to be seen after all
negotiations are still at an early age
however the success of Barbie also a
Mattel product could be a crucial reason
as to why the streaming giant is making
such an effort the last time He-Man was
seen in the movies was in the late 80s
starring Dolph
lungren we have news about the emotions
next year we can finally look forward to
the sequel to The Pixar hit inside out
as part of the trailer releases a number
of new emotion characters have now been
revealed and they will play an important
part in the sequel the story of Riley
and her emotions will continue in inside
out too with one big change Riley is
reaching puberty this means that all
kinds of new emotions will join the
previous ones for example the emotion
anxiety already appears in the first
trailer saying I'm sorry we wanted to
make such a good first impression in
addition to anxiety the Wii also
includes onwe envy and embarrassment
these emotions are also mentioned in the
trailer's end credits which Begin by
saying the feel-good movie of the year
shortly afterwards the word good changes
to the many other emotions which can
also be seen to some extent in the first
images while fans are particularly
excited that the successful 2015 film is
getting a sequel in the first place we
wonder whether these new four emotions
will be all we can look forward to the
makers hinted beforehand that we could
be in for as many as 27 emotions however
it can be strongly assumed that not
every single one of them will play major
role as confusing as puberty may be
viewers have to be able to keep a bit of
an overview of
course that's it for this week's Koch
Che news should you happen to be in the
mood to play some games right now you
should definitely check out our overview
of the best upcoming video game
adaptations first there are some really
awesome game adaptations waiting for us
in the coming years should you be more
into monster action don't worry we also
got a preview on Godzilla xong the new
Empire on our Channel thanks for
watching and see you next time for more
Koch Che
[Music]
news